hey welcome back to our channel my name
is samuel and i'm amanda and this
is the samuel and amanda show or as some
people say the samanda show
um so this week we are going to be
viewing beautiful mansions
in and around the london area now this
to be honest this is the first time
we've ever done this
on youtube or on the podcast however we
do do this
all the time yeah we're constantly on
right move looking at houses
yeah although actually this isn't going
to work as a podcast oh yeah
so this is gonna have to just be youtube
online it's a youtube special so if
you're listening then you need to head
on to samuel lee's
youtube channel and watch this video
because we're gonna be talking about
properties and you need to be able to
see
one of the biggest pastimes that we have
i mean some people call it property porn
i don't know is that is that a crew
thing to say though
it's property porn a crude thing sounds
a little bit crude what does it mean
what does property porn mean
i don't know it's just like when you're
like well porn is like when you're like
listening over something isn't it so i'm
guessing it's like lusting over property
well yeah i don't know it's just
visually pleasing you know looking at
properties visually pleasing
yeah some people look at cars look at
cars and oh you know
um what about people call cars i always
find this cringy when they call a thing
as she
so they'll say like oh isn't she
beautiful oh yeah yeah
a little bit cringey there's a house of
[ __ ] or is a house no i think a house is
just like an inanimate object
you wouldn't say imagine if you said
about house isn't he beautiful
people do that with cars and wigs people
call their wigs like sheep and they do
it with ships
ships oh really yeah they'll say isn't
she beautiful which i think
a ship is probably the only thing where
it doesn't sound right yeah yeah
so we're gonna be looking at pictures of
houses uh we're gonna be on right move
scrolling through and you should be able
to see on the screen the houses that
we're looking at
and we want to know what you think do
you think amanda's got a good taste
we've got a weirdly exact sound taste
yeah we have we have we like the same
type of houses
and yeah we just in sync to the point
where
when i'm looking for a house for me to
live in ie for us to live in
sometimes amanda's chosen the house and
i haven't even seen it and she's just
text me and don't forget we moved house
today here's your new postcode
yeah that's happening and i've just
driven to a new house because that's how
much i trust amanda yeah so while i get
right move up what have you been up to
this week this week's been
super chilled i've actually i talked
about me
on my weight loss journey um early on
and i've now lost half a stern that's
incredible and i've been doing it
through just clean eating and not even
like super it's not a diet
but i haven't even been exercising but
i've just been eating well
and controlling what i eat thinking
about what i'm eating and being
intentional about what i'm eating so
that's brilliant that's been really good
so yeah
oh i haven't been about much no i've
been running the
deal finding extravaganza and the deal
selling masterclass and i've literally
been away for like five days straight
however i had the best time ever there
if you were at the program if you're the
deal say masterclass congratulations
because you're actually out buying
houses
um all right good so here we go
i mean this 3.75 million that's actually
in beckham's field
wow i don't i don't really love that
that much you know i don't love the
fence
i think that just the fences yeah it
makes it
rubbish i think the inside looks really
nice there yeah
it's pretty nice i don't love the
kitchen that much i think it's a nice
house
no cinema yeah jam it's nice
but we can do better it's nice look at
this house
this has five million pounds in
beckham's field that looks very homely i
like that
what is the inside well these all in
because i think i might need to i like
this house
this is nice oh i love the staircase who
i mean that is just nice and its goals
isn't it to have your staircase in the
middle and then like goes upstairs and
then it's a big
landing upstairs the kitchen's not
amazing a bit underwhelming
i also don't like how the kitchen it
looks like the front door's just there
by the stairs and
it's a bit too open plan i think yeah
and also the island
is too small yes you kind of want to be
able to sit around the island yeah why
would you have a kitchen that big and
yeah it's a bit
dated on the inside as well these are
all in beckham's field
and although i love beckons field i want
to do
a little bit further afield as well okay
let's do let's do let's do 20 miles from
beckham's field
7000 results but we're going to start
from of course highest price
it's got to be done yeah now it's going
to be impressive
now it's going to be impressive okay how
is that the highest how is 20 million
the highest that can't be right can it
that's crazy
20 million cannot be the highest price
within 20 miles
let's do 30 miles 20 million now
here we go oh this is still 20 million
yeah it is and that's five bedrooms
this is london though right like london
you're just paying more for just living
in london
yeah that's nice it's nice it's all
right you don't like it it's a bit too
modern i love the look of it yeah i like
it oh my gosh that looks
so grand like oh i love that
see it says poi but then if you oh
there's another one again
okay poi so we don't know how much it is
no we don't know i how much would you
guess that is
i would say well it doesn't seem
it's in sorry yeah so it's not in
central london that is
cool okay that looks so grand i don't
even know like if you'd want to live in
there you won't want to
have it messy or anything no that that's
what i mean by a good island yeah that
kitchen is
nice it's such a cool it looks like a
house in beverly hills like
yeah different courses
do you think you'd ever actually play
tennis or do you think you would just
enjoy having a tennis court
i think you'd just enjoy saying oh yes i
have a tennis court in my backyard
look at that that is stunning
nice house that's my favorite house so
far that is really nice
it's so grand it's very grand it's
almost a little bit too grand
yeah like look at the garage it's even
got like
um like a marble floor would you feel at
home there
probably not how many rooms 11 bedrooms
probably not i think you would
do it i mean i'd like it this house this
house is in virginia water i don't know
if we've
actually driven past this i don't think
we've seen that one um
i love the staircase yeah i love that to
be fair
there's gonna be parts that you love to
a house that's 20 million pounds if
there wasn't it would be crazy
what do you think of the outside the
look the color i don't love it i don't
love it i don't love the white i don't
know i just don't really
feel it that much no no that looks awful
yeah we won't even look at that one i
don't like that one
it looks like a barn it looks nice in
that light
but 20 million pounds and uh and you've
got a house that looks like that
and like like a really i wanted
everyone to be envious of my house if i
was living in a house that was 20
million
and also they've had to take pictures
in the perfect light on the perfect day
just to make it look like yeah to sell
it
i mean it's not bowling alley wasn't it
yeah a ball and going a bowling alley
there
oh yeah they must love berlin
yeah decent deep that's just that is not
a good house isn't it
i can't believe that's 19 million it's
not nice
it doesn't look no and again
like some of these i guess that's just
because it's how can that be
17 and a half million offers in excess
of it's just the area but it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter i know i never but
it's london
no but it doesn't matter where it is
why would anybody spend 17 and a half
million i just can't
yeah i don't know babe okay 17 i want to
find something that's just amazing but
not
ridiculously expensive yeah that's nice
that is nice sure stimulating for an
eight bed
that looks awful that is that looks
i'm gonna um it looks like a council
like block of flats
but this is not even attractive no it's
not
they should have done something with the
outside whoever developed it
we like beckonsfield a lot i love that
that
that's it it's very nice that's it
that's a really nice house
and it i love houses that are really i
don't know like luxurious and look
really nice but also still look homely
and
you know and not so in your face from
the outside also houses that are kind of
like
slightly understated yeah they're not
like
look at me yeah i'm the they're really
nice what about the house remember when
we looked at the house and alberts
bromley and oh my gosh it was
overlooking water which is just amazing
loads and loads of water but it was kind
of understated yeah it was when you went
in you were wowed but on the outside
it was just really nice to look at but
not that's got to be one of my favourite
houses i'm not yeah that's very nice
that's a very nice look nice kitchen it
is it's homely isn't it yeah it's homely
nice stairs that's nice i like that
nice ball it's just nice
and it's got balcony i'm obsessed it's
got underground parking as well
i'm obsessed with balconies aren't i yes
samuel
when we look at houses like has it got a
balcony if you want to get me
if you want to if you want me to be a
sucker when you're selling a house you
want to have a balcony
you want to have palm trees i mean it
doesn't cost anything practically
palm trees you could just literally just
buy a palm tree
no a couple hundred pounds and install a
couple punches in the gun suddenly i'm
sold
i'll pay an extra million i'll pay an
extra million but this is just oh look
at that what's that
that looks like one of those things you
know tony robbins where he has that cool
yeah that really
cold yeah everybody jump yeah it looks
like that
stunning views love that love that house
nice amazing yes baby
daddy's busy okay you go away bye
um oh my god okay this house i don't
really like that
i don't like it's like when it's again
oh it's been sold by the looks of it
good we don't want it anyway bye bye
um also another thing is another another
way to get men as a sucker
is we both like white houses don't we
yeah we do
we like them to look nice and modern and
fresh almost like a house that you'd see
abroad
in england that's what where you feel
like you're on holiday yeah
that house sucks doesn't it yeah that
house sucks sorry
it just doesn't no
decent nice yeah decent
it's so funny how different people have
different tastes i remember when i went
to
um meet with leon who's built his own
house
and his friend next door has also built
his own house yeah and they're both
actually my students but the houses have
been done
so differently one's kind of got like
that english
kind of old-fashioned nice it's very
modern just that
kind of slight cottage cottages and the
other ones all
steel windows glass wow
but they're both really nice yeah just
in different ways yeah exactly yeah this
is nice nice water out the front
i don't like the house though no i also
think if you're gonna have water out the
front
the water needs to look clean that looks
like a dirty duck bond
yeah that it's nice the water but would
you really no
i don't really like that one actually do
not no 12 million mandy goes now i'm all
right
um see that looks again average
it that looks like a block of apartments
or something i don't really like the
look of that at all
that's quite nice that's nice that's
nice see the white sort of house
i bet there's a palm tree in the garden
but there is that oh yes
wow look at how we have a winner best
buy would be nice best value for money
house on
right move eleven nine uh eleven i just
say eleven nine nine five
i can't even get the numbers out it's so
big um
i don't think i've ever bought anything
anywhere near that in my life
uh 11950 right there's a lot of zeros
it's almost as long as mine
although it does look like i don't love
the interior it's a bit
like old school i don't really like it a
lot of houses like that in virginia
water that won't matter
yeah i think it's because it's an older
generation that own them
and that's why and they think that it
looks really good yeah they think that
that's like oh really
cool but nowadays but come on look at
that
i think the actual building is really
really nice
so amanda tell us what do you look for
in a
home not a property investment oh i love
a drive into the house like a driveway
and ideally i'd love it if it had like a
roundabout as well that would be really
really cool
well so you come in and you can circle
around circle around
that's really cool i also love it when
you can walk around the whole house
yeah i love that i just think it's cool
yeah
uh i like i love a nice kitchen with an
island
i think that's really because i feel
like we spend so much time in the
kitchen it's nice to have a bigger
when you say we spend so much time on
kitchen who are you talking about me and
the kids
although i hang in the kitchen yeah you
hang in the kitchen
in our kitchen it's quite big so i like
that as well i also
love a good dressing room in the master
in the master bedroom yeah
that is like yeah i think ideally what i
what i'd love bib is a big dressing room
and then an island
in the dressing room as well an island
an island in the dressing room so you're
not in the
at the moment we've got like the big
poof circle poop in the middle oh yeah
you have an island oh my god it has
extra stuff but yeah it's really cool so
i love
yeah i love i love balconies palm trees
white houses
private gates i also like we haven't got
this but i would like potential like
is when you open the door to your house
you've just got this
like a big open space with the uh like a
hall
a big hallway yeah then the stairs right
in front of you and then the stairs go
up and then they circle you can walk
around the top right and then in the
hallway you go off into different rooms
then you go up the stairs which are
grand there um and then you go upstairs
and then there's like um
you can walk around at the top go off
into the different rooms
balconies on the outside balconies on
the master bedroom
um i used to think i really badly wanted
a swimming pool
but i've got to say it having a swim spa
i know yeah that's kind of taken it
takes yeah
yeah well it fulfills it it's so big
yeah and it's like that cost us 30
000 pounds but it's outside which is
nice because
it's just fresh and refreshing rather
than when you're only going to a
swimming pool
if you have a swimming pool in your
house you're going in and it's just a
bit humid
yeah it's nice to be outside with the
fresh air or the snow
hitting you but even when it's cooler
it's nice to be outside it's just fresh
crispy
have the water as hot or cold as you
want it's kind of like kills two birds
it's got clawing and it's not like a
pool outside that's cold and mucky
you know so it's clean it's got chlorine
in it um
it's outside that's kind of ticked the
box for me so now i'm
you know so um and also as well i like
houses where they're up so it feels like
they're on a hill almost oh yeah you
love
that yeah yeah there's nothing worse
than a house
that's like in a slump yeah like that's
one of the things that put me off high
wickham
the whole of high wickham is in is is in
a yeah what do you call it
almost a pit not a pit i think it's
just because of so many hills like when
you're in the center you're kind of in
the
well down low down yeah low down i like
to be high up
i like houses and i also really like you
know houses where they're so high up
that even
you could have like a garage you can
just drive in straight in but the house
is almost on a rise
yeah you like that i really like that um
good for views
i like to feel high your home should be
like your castle you know it's like yeah
this is my castle this is my home and if
it's if it's uh
high up it just has a really nice
feeling so that's what i like
so do you guys also do what we do
because what you've just seen us do is
pretty much what we do
almost i won't say every night but we do
it really yeah
we regularly send each other links to
houses on rightmost like oh check this
out or do you like that
we look at houses for rent we look at
houses for sale we look all across the
country we're looking
um down the south coast we look at fancy
mansions
with the beach and stuff like that um
around where we live
so do you do it as well that's our
guilty pleasure also
man do you think that us loving property
and looking at houses and stuff do you
think that has any relevance to our
actual property investment business or
do you think it's completely separate
because when we're investing it's all
about formulas or do you think that
you kind of have to love property a
little bit to be very successful in
property
oh i think you have to love property i
think you have to be very
interested i mean i think what we do it
just depends what your strategy is
i think in what we do it's quite cool to
see what sort of houses people
what what what's on the market what's
what people are liking if we're building
houses
and stuff i know we don't build like big
mansions and stuff but i think it's just
i think you kind of have to be immersed
in it in every which way if you
if you do love property and you want to
be successful yeah and everything is as
well
i think it's really important to
visualize the life that you want
and i remember when i used to go running
even as a teenager i'd go jogging
and i'd go to the the nice parts of town
and look at the nice houses and
visualize living there yeah
and i personally think that's that's
really important not just to
you know write down your goal but also
to have a vision board and actually
see your goal i think it's really really
really important so okay
final words of wisdom okay well just
following off following on from what you
said i'd probably say then so when it
comes to goals
don't just say it see it so visualize
your goals
have the vision board up there look at
it every day yeah
love that guys i hope you enjoyed this
comment your thoughts below if there's
anything particular themes that you want
to see us talk about or hear us talk
about
let us know in the comment box below and
we'll see you guys next
week same time same place see you guys
bye